hello everybody in a row ah worth it
hello everybody and welcome to drunk
minecraft with William - mark and I have
a really tough day with me Wade myself
and I I'm finishing off his bottle wine
and large and ball hey that's a great oh
no oh no no no no no no no no no -
screws
did you guys hear the sound of the
creeper they see me around our house oh
right there ultimately ruining
everything
finishing a reference of my beau there's
a cavern under here so I just killed a
bottle of wine at whatever there's a
cavern a cavern where where big-ass
cavern what whoa whoa oh my you're dying
and I die you're dying you're 900 no no
no them hey I saved me oh no come on
damn it
hahaha save me by not selling it to a
pig that's hilarious
oh that is the best vulva down here why
don't you get down oh yeah I gave you
the diamond for that
okay I'm going down in this hole cuz I
want to take my [ __ ] no you got your
[ __ ] all right all right there all right
so anyway wait we need to get a redstone
torch wait we need to get going in the
Lord just his big was a really good
sound that you may push I know this good
oh god oh god I was thinking it was like
water and it helped me get down but it
was lava and I was like I thought for
some reason I thought if I jump in it
then I can jump out oh oh effort is
crazy all my [ __ ] burn - where are you
hang are you down yeah okay I'm going
down oh I need to not all right
she made it diamond
hey someone teleport to me No
so we'll always work away from where we
are why no I not [ __ ] there's a lot
of [ __ ] down here that we gotta explore
cuz we haven't really split these
caverns the Quaid and I tried but
so somebody teleport to me no I'm
standing on glowstone next to all [ __ ] -
Nikola netherrack instead I see it
that's where we got all that iron right
was by the glows - ah ha ha ah you guys
are so bad at this game
enchanted armor and pickaxe you lays yes
I don't have time to get all this though
- zombie all my stuff it burns
oh it just burned up oh it's on its way
oh yeah oh yeah
Oh someday this power is gonna go to my
head and then like zombies gonna be like
no someday but no oh wait world what are
we on all unbreaking 5 fortune for
efficiency 5 yeah here's such piece of
[ __ ] oh god I love it I love it so
where's all this coal I don't know is is
it enough here please look up find it
all on top of the glowstone see it okay
how do we know I'm in projection for
blast protection for protection for
projectile protection for protection for
fire protection 1 protection for M boots
oh it's not like you earned it
shut up I earned it by being an awesome
youtuber that's not why you earned it
you know why your awesome art was of
your fans saying okay because you're gay
you know in other people our games if
you wear a shirt with a rainbow on it
that says I love balls in my mouth
I'm does not say that mine says
Cincinnati Bearcats you know you know
how I was just quoting 40 year old
virgin I don't you know how I know
you're gay why does it the seat move you
know how I know you're gay who are you
talking to
Bob oh wait no matter how do you know
that wait is gay how do we know that Bob
is gay because he likes the taste of my
dick in his mouth ah oh my [ __ ] is gone
oh man pit bull per se I thought you
were laughing at that and I thought I
felt good about myself a good time huh
funniest joke ever that's actually a
quote from 40 L versus Bob you scared
the [ __ ] out of me hey buddy wait where
are you guys TP Oh Lord
Bob oh here's all this stuff you know
Bob what are we gonna get a divorce what
are we getting a divorce because there's
lots of hot ladies all wanting to marry
me somebody I was you mean they Jennifer
and that other one that other one who's
the other one I don't know I can't
remember more easy or kill thanks though
dick axe please don't actually in me
Alan no I will not you I hate you so
much I miss you but down here
yes we're um oh yeah there's all that
wood over by the trainer yeah there's a
bunch of wood go figure
oh yeah how about that but no wait still
no the answer's no eat you
hey I hate you equally this mean to me
because you can take it mister whoosh
I'll give you that Boosh me oh no that's
where the lava is I don't know why but
there's some lag on the surf right now
where things don't break immediately
like guess you have to re-break but I
looked at it is unpretty damn sweet I
mean I love me yeah whatever no one else
does hey Mark well I'm inside to you oh
yeah I see boom well you are my husband
wife so I suppose it's all you know
perfectly okay what are we doing anyway
we're supposed to go down here for iron
right we need to build this house I'm
going I want to get out you know what I
wish I wish that have you ever played
terraria yeah I have just for a little
bit I wish you could get the mining hat
from terraria in Minecraft
what is the mining and terraria it's a
piece of armor that's a helmet that has
a light on it oh so you have a light in
front of
son of a [ __ ] to be back my crafting
table oh I didn't take it I should hit
it and it just disappeared and you
picked it up no I really don't have it I
here's all the stuff that's on me right
now besides my parents dibs dibs dibs
dibs it's a one rail glows on each for
more wood oh poor baby
Oh everybody's feel so sorry for Wade
please no okay
oh by the way still taking open
applications for a girlfriend position
not me you said it your resumes to
markipliergame at gmail.com yeah totally
I sent you one did you get it yeah I may
or may not be awesome I know you look
really good naked Bob I'm just saying
that like as a compliment to you that is
not a thing that I knew you were aware
of I'm not saying you're wrong
I didn't I I know you washed me when we
live together yeah totally yeah no no
totally man yeah yeah I could appreciate
good art you know when you drink it up I
pick it up I think hey yeah what you got
now I got a working device yeah your guy
are you suck you dress what what now how
do you get all that urn how'd you get
that I got some armor like a day I got
an iron starter set urn for me I don't
even know what's going on
aah-aah-aah jumped in a law firm
once I get powered rail one my mark just
hit uh-oh
your home is probably not our house
that's not it's not it's not that's not
good nope oh [ __ ] how are you doing hey
I got ported back you can port to me oh
I got ported on to the penis
me too hahaha oh I thought you were on
top of the penis [ __ ] okay in spite of
all once the penis is extra food yeah it
is
Oh kit get in there nice and deep boy
but I bet I poop from there oh my god
I don't know what you're doing hahaha
none of you know the other line to that
no no no anybody knows other line from
that if you do know don't don't just
don't pretend like there's another line
oh there is no they both know what's
going on here it goes it goes but I poop
from there not right now you don't top
of my pitches I can't get - oh God oh
this is not PG all advertisers are gonna
abandon me what's with these cows by the
way are we doing anything with these
cows yeah they refill our Bulls we don't
have any bowls you're a bunch of bolts
inside oh where you're a liar you're
dirty liar there's balls full of
mushrooms you're a freakin liar I swear
God if you don't stop lying to me I'm in
the last episode Bob said hey I'm
filling up lots of bowls of mushroom
stew I don't see [ __ ] there's nothing in
here best episode no there's a think I
did I'm looking at the boxers there's
literally nothing here there's Bulls
full of them no there's nothing here at
all I just got three oh there's nothing
here I'm telling you I was just there
there's nothing there no look there's
nothing there
there's one right here there's one one
doesn't help
you said there were dozens there were
you parts at this one right here - where
look three I can't even go in these
chests here we go wait Han okay there's
one yeah there's one there were more but
I took some you took all of them I took
three I don't know what happened to the
rest every Bob Bob what did you do I'm
climbing the peanut oil
ah you're destroying the penis Bob
you're circumcising it
oh wow I don't think you know what
circumcising me and here's already kind
of circumcised you're kind of just tip
the strobing I don't a sex-change
operation going on with this penis right
why why do we listen to go there these
episodes are gonna be bad I know I know
they are okay Oh God
yes again okay from now on did you die
thank you so much okay from now on we're
happy fun times PG up child-friendly oh
my god
what we're out well we're like out of em
are on the Pertino we'll call any time
it's only 11 minutes in really yeah oh I
should never have agreed to this ha ha
you gotta go really kinda really why
your girlfriend no oh why so I have a
life no you don't have a life you have
drunk minecraft uh is this laughs you
speak though mask you shun do you really
think you have a laugh Bob who think you
have a laugh but you don't we gotta go
child friendly that was child friendly
no peen or aha Oh Oh God you died that's
hilarious
I don't know I wanted this looks like
from a distance now yeah oh that is that
is just sad looking blow it up make it
ugly oh sweet baby Jesus ah wait if you
Bob if you have to go that's fine I
suppose we could finish this up without
you alrighty
we just rag on you the entire time just
put the tea and that's fine who is well
listen to you two zombie I'll see you
guys oh it's being wrapped with TNT
Bob is going uh-huh you said I could
well I didn't mean it I didn't think you
actually Donna hello everybody look at
the drunk minecraft we're bomb abandons
us yeah totally you don't need me
Wow Oh closer closer
why did you go there I don't know I
don't know let me in the penis oh no no
no no no no no no no no no no you're
alone you have no armor how did you
survive her a kid friendly guy we're PG
now that was a penis that was not a PG I
was not a a private part how long before
we say [ __ ] or something I so long gosh
job you don't get it the first episode
seems to panco can I say [ __ ] you guys
your life no your yes well you just said
it and now I say go you don't want to
say that no you've gotta be PG Bob are
you Don's this
what are you still here yeah oh I
thought you were gone I was waiting for
that to blow up okay are you gonna go
yes will we get for recording episodes
at 6:00 in the morning that happened I'm
trapped okay here we go all right
bye-bye
all right everyone say bye to bomb you
guys this episode I get Wireless yeah Oh
Bob has a real life in a real job oh I
think Bob is gone by Bob logged off oh
it's so sad now oh but you know what we
could do now wait si log off what can we
do now mask you Shum madam you think you
can ask me but you can't - ha ha ha bad
you dumb what do you think we're doing
out here Rick I think we're trying to
survive Shane and make sure everyone
else survives - Mac you come knows we're
alive under your leaders focus don't
ring
Matthew zoom not mask you man mask you
some masks you tell me man you're about
to have a seizure Rick I'm Terry
no zombie ring who are you come here a
mask mask you Joe
I guess I'll break again are you Rick I
don't know yes you saw who are you I'm
doing this for Karl
I've heard that everything I do is for
cold you know it right it really doesn't
go like that you know you think you love
her but you do it's you think you love
her but you don't that's how it I don't
know how it turned it up you think you
love her but you don't I don't know I
think that's a mixture of Rick and Shane
going on there what's don't you think
you lover but you don't Oh spider you
think you know this farm but you don't
this is my farm my wife my son I'm the
only one who can meet his father I'm a
better father than you Rick you'll never
be a better father than I am saying we
like gonna having weight at risk you're
willing to sacrifice too much we think
what's gonna happen when the longer cuts
out that maybe I don't know what you
just said that's my baby and not your
baby it is the price spoiler spoiler
alert there's a baby there's a buyer
hippie oh by the way hey wait come here
for a second wait come here wait come
here wait come here where are you I'm
right here alright here we go ready
honest look at me I'm stuck in wood
looking why is this here look at me look
at me Oh
look at me look at me I can't
I'm Johnston jump you douche oh good now
okay yes ah yeah ah yeah ah yeah ah yeah
ah no I got I got it back huh huh wha
why cuz I took it off from the chess I
made you think that I didn't have it but
I did mad Mac ah I just did the Cthulhu
thing you did I remember no one knows I
don't know what that is it
no knows what that is you I don't even
know what the
haha people out there do you know what
that is you don't know it was barking at
a bar when I just are kicked up ha ha
yeah we had all these ladies dancing
baby are you good yeah that's good oh go
on
that's how it was miss how it be don't
you
I wish I had more wine but I'm all I
drink this whole bottle I used to wonder
why I'm single oh really
because I'm about to get a slew of
emails from random girls around the
around the world and align hopefully as
a tomorrow gonna know whether or not I
still in oh I just did tavern face you
ready simultaneous tavern face okay
three two one no do your protection
oh ho oh you did you little zhuzh what
was that the other fabulous top you do
you love how about you go home and do
nothing but you just you say to us of
the day you another potato dishonor me
your friendship horrible absolutely
horrendous this this episode is devolved
into alcohol is bad OS oh ma if you guys
didn't know who's watching I keep
forgetting that people are actually
watching this bob was a dick and got us
drinking way before he actually showed
up like three or four and then he leaves
yeah he loves little each the booze
what a dick and we started doing 30
minutes long he should have been able to
stick around everyone write in the
comments Bob is a giant dude Bob
officially now as a guide do so right
the comically Bob is a giant douche cuz
I like I I don't usually drink wine but
this was fun I like wine drunk wine
drunk it's fun drunk
I want more wine I want more
oh I want it I want it I want it okay
anyway so what are we doing what do we
do I was rebuilding your father what
happened to the farm when did it blow up
the tea and tea from the giant censored
ah well what the eff this isn't it is
getting out of hand
sis you heard me this shish kebab is
just too much for me to handle
paddy a dummy good night King Diamond
enchanted ho really right now right CB
you don't know the perks of having your
own channel come in be coming right up
did you see that oh yeah
you called him zooming bead so it's like
Zumba Doom is good for you no cuz there
was no cut there was no vowel it was all
constant it's no one knows it's the very
end no knows what you're talking about
wait your giant idiot rewind and look
where he says zmm bie ya go ho aqua
affinity whoa no no this is the one that
spawns water oh oh I still have your
crafting table by the way I love a
wooden pickaxe haha you so stupid and
oaky you are who is ugly do you all
think I'm ugly and stupid yeah they do
people out there who is more attractive
let's just settle this what's after all
who is more attractive me or wait and
his pictures right in whoa whoa who's
more jagged we're way I can't see Wade
right now but I like it we'll be
together in the face that man ridiculous
Oh God oh that's how I make water look
at me mark look right at me
I'm looking at you Wade I'm looking at
you I can almost reach out and touch you
I'm trying to touch you Oh drunk seating
try and reel out there wants to join us
in a big group touching session why is
this water floating right here because
because it's this HOH makes water see
watch this well ground you [ __ ] that's
useful it is useful it's not working
water yeah it's got a cool down damper
this camper your face damper your mom I
was gonna say that but then I realized
my mom's the one that gets all the jokes
your mom's the one that gets all the
action no response no comment to that
it's true Nash really really I mean I
had a newborn son hahahaha
you know you think about that if if any
of you out there want to be creeped out
just remember for you often born for you
to be born your parents had to have hot
steamy sex and PG just turned into not
rain just just keep that in mind folks
out there this is the Unrated extended
plant Oh God
extended if you know what I mean oh you
think you know what you mean but you
don't just rip myself I thought I had my
shovel but I didn't I don't think this
yes so this one I do that this does not
work anymore
Nicole so Rick why don't you go in the
house and just take a nap you look tired
Rick I'm go for a walk in the woods say
yeah totally rip it
we were once best friends no reason we
couldn't be best friends again
I agree oh [ __ ] mind if I take up I'm
gonna scream too big too loud on that
one I thought you actually died it's
really [ __ ] up
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha you died oh that's
fantastic I love that so much I know
there's so much I love that uh water
everywhere oops I gotta stop using this
hope I have a door Oh God why is there
water down here get my stuff because I
accidentally spawned water with my hoe
hope you do very often I know I know
oh really
what sorry unab leap that out in post
Wow bleep I'm really gonna go back and
sleep that sleep that out that was just
out it bad that was really bad if all
are you listening now you don't know
what I said because I blinked about the
best believe it for the best nobody
needed to hear that I don't worry no one
needed here though I was ready for that
that was so bad
Wow ha ha ha oh [ __ ] your farm just got
blown up
Oh why I don't know I Rick you don't
know what's best for this farm you think
you do but you don't shame your you're
not willing to cross the lines I am
you're not willing to go the distance I
am yeah I got a bottle up this wine for
nobodies not enabled I want more why I
don't either one of us really needs more
trees just you know you know I normally
don't drink wine but I'm really
surprised that I drink this whole bottle
in like the span of 4 hours
well thank thank Bob for that thank Bob
for them liam is here to thank I mean
honestly for people who drink wine I bet
out there who drink a lot of wine this
isn't that much I mean for serious winos
out there you could drink like bottles
and bottles of wine but the four are for
me this is like a first for me
wait who there's wheat crop it up what's
going on things are building up around
me Lou
things didn't building up out of nowhere
yeah alright so I got all this mushroom
stew that I stole from the chest and
made you think that they were gone
one of the hell cuz I'm so sneaky like
that so you do this so I didn't believe
you and now you're admitting that you
were just being taken you yeah yeah
pretty much all right what am I not
being a dick
Oh a good point I mean honestly come on
if we're just being perfectly honest
here what am I not being a dick whatever
this game I'm gonna leave you I'm gonna
ask people on the server am i a dick
say yes be honest Blanc would appreciate
your honesty a dick am i a douche mark
look what I made what what did you make
I'm so excited to see what the hell you
made what is that what is that is that a
penis it's a replica of something we
used to have wait that's how I might
what no I don't have it I will have the
one in the background that's true it's
not as majestic as the other one but at
least it's like longer than it is wide
this time yeah I know what I'm doing
it's got some stuff in it uh I'm not
gonna respond to that particular so how
much should I believe in this this
episode will be titled Bob's obtuse
sense of ha ha Oh guys so bad we're
actually getting close we only got like
three minutes left it's crime for the
best cuz we've not done are we gonna do
something since I'm starving
make something happen three minutes left
something oh man something amazing
he hasn't been [ __ ] with us like
summers episode Ian's like nothing's
happened since then it's part for the
best y'all
now it's gonna happen Oh God
screw with us my body is ready
bring it on Sunday I'm just training
it's like it's epic shower time with
markiplier is it no that's just Jennifer
so far the only fan I probably shot
nothing come
so the Fannie's holy friend you showered
with yeah yeah something like that
it was an out-of-body experience for you
yeah I know it was totally in body if
you know what I mean
Oh oh god I'm so sorry go image it
I'm so sorry Jennifer I'm so sorry oh
god I'm a douche why isn't zombie making
stuff happen it's kind of raining on us
it could be epic shower time for both of
us together oh yeah you want to get
naked already there you are your webcams
upset people couldn't believe that oh
well Oh what just happen what my dead
adios what just happened
I don't know ah why is that Wow
those my early days what are you do it
don't go over right now we need your
help I need your elbow I need your help
I need your any girl I just got naked
got my ass kicked I don't have any
weapons I only have a pig oh my god
look why are we not we're never prepared
for this oh my I was not ready for this
Abbott oh my god I don't
I hate those things like fire-spitting
douchebag from the nether god laughs
we're gonna hate you and they don't drop
anything oh they're killing all our cows
no no the mushrooms oh the mushrooms i
ah
like that's enough that's enough stuff
ah I can't even type oh mercy like a hey
laughs you think you can have our four
but you can't okay we're out of time for
the 13 episode anyway this is the last
series in this this is the last
recording in the series that we're gonna
do so please let us know what you think
of the 30 minute episodes as opposed to
the 45 minutes like obviously you'll
notice that we really some sooner than
the 45 minute one oh you mean the last
one we're doing it right now yeah for
now we just want I want to get a get an
idea so please let us know in the
comments below also let us know that Bob
is a douche for abandoning us and also I
do not shower with fans just talking it
out up there alright so thank you all so
much for watching
what and as always we'll see you in the
next part bye bye bye everybody